In this lesson, we're going to take a look at Nanite and virtual shadowmaps.
So let's get started.
So many people ask, like, why Nanite?
Why use it?
Well, it's Unreal 5's virtualized geometry system.
Basically, it's a lot more complex than our regular LODs because we get a higher visual
fidelity because it's stored as a hierarchical system of smaller parts using triangles and
adds geometric complexity with less issues.
So it sorts it quite well, and it keeps that silhouette and the higher poly look and feel
for that object on a more consistent, believable basis.
So Nanite allows for higher visual fidelity and works well with Lumen.
So when you're using Nanite, try to use it with Lumen as much as possible.
It doesn't mean you can't use it with a regular baked system.
It just takes a lot of time, and you may be limited, especially if you need several different
higher poly objects.
You want to lean towards Lumen and virtual shadowmaps when using Nanite.
Outside of Lumen, again, like I said before, it can't take a while to bake those shadows.
Virtual shadowmaps are used for more high fidelity shadows versus baking shadows.
When you bake, you're sharing that information.
You're putting it into a texture.
It's baking it on the environment, especially for static objects and your static lighting.
It's not quite as visually unique and in the fact that it actually brings in more realism.
So the suspension of disbelief is better with Lumen, with Nanite, and with virtual shadowmaps.
So instant object count and draw calls are less of a limitation now, and instances are
in the millions versus what we had before.
So again, that beats LODs again.
So it's more visually accurate than displacement and has a less shadow artifacts.
But that doesn't mean you can't use displacement.
You can still add it to your object, which we'll talk about in just a second.
So the issues that come up with displacement is it's inaccurate because you're actually
pushing the object's visual look beyond the original bounds of the object.
Now if you do run into any kind of flickering or weird drawing issues happening, you can
actually go into the object itself and increase the bounds just a tad, just a little bit,
that's all it needs.
And you can maybe edit some of those.
But for the most part, Nanite makes it so that you don't necessarily have to lean so
hard on displacement.
So Nanite is great for a high resolution model and shadows keeping accuracy and working with
virtual shadowmaps.
So again, no, Nanite can be used for ICB effects, but baking takes a good amount of time outside
of virtual shadowmaps.
Lumen, Nanite, virtual shadowmaps are ideal for ICB effects, but also can be used for
games, but both you need to be very deterministic as you work with them.
So let's go and take a look in Unreal.
And I'm going to point out some of the features that we have in here to be able to edit some
of your Nanite qualities.
Now I'm not going to get too much into buttonology, but I will walk you through the overall synopsis
of what they are.
And I do have them listed in my notes too, so never fear if you think you will forget.
So let's go ahead and take a look in Unreal and we're going to take a look at Nanite overall.
I'm going to go and click on this particular rock.
Let's go and click on our magnifying glass.
Find that rock and we're going to actually mess with this copy here.
We have a copy in here.
I'm going to right click this particular one and we can see that we can easily and instantly
turn this into a Nanite object.
You can also disable it if you want to.
So this Nanite object, we can now double click on it.
Let's go full screen and we're in our scene and you'll see that we have some Nanite settings.
Let's isolate these a little bit better so we can actually talk about them.
So I'm just going to type in Nanite in general.
There you go.
Got to be able to type and you'll see all of our settings in place.
Now these allow you for a little bit more micro managing where you can actually edit things
according to the needs of that object.
You'll see obviously number one, we have enable Nanite support.
This is actually super important and will now automatically tick on before you had to
go in here and turn that on.
This makes it so that Nanite is going to be drawn correctly.
So Unreal automatically knows this is a Nanite object and it's ready to be drawn.
We have a preserved area one in here now and this one can help with foliage, especially
if you have like minute details that aren't rendering the way that you like.
You actually can turn that on to maybe help things out.
There's also explicit tangents.
Now this is used to help store model tangents per asset versus runtime.
So if you needed to for optimization purposes, you have that option.
There's also position precision here.
Can't say that correctly.
It's used to help calculate, generate the vertex positions of a Nanite mesh and can
be adjusted for optimization.
So if you need to, you can.
And then we also have normal precision and this is for optimizing the disc footprint
and enables choosing the precision mesh that should be used when generating vertex normal.
So you actually have that here to be able to choose.
So there's a few more here and we've actually expanded these and we try to make these better
and better with each build.
That hasn't changed a whole heck of a lot, but we have made it so that just to make your
life easier because if you have a huge world you're building or you're in this case optimizing
things for ICV effects, you can actually manage things, especially if things get a little bit
big.
So we have a minimum residency here, root geometry.
This sets the memory bite size and streams rest for optimization.
So you have that option there.
There's keep triangle percent.
This again used for to optimize the triangle usage.
And we also have trim relative error here.
This sets a maximum relative error amounts.
You can do so if you need to fall back target.
We talked a little bit about this in previous classes.
It's used to help generating the appropriate fallback mesh.
It determines which targeting system used when generating a fallback mesh overall.
Auto works pretty well.
You can automatically create a fallback mesh based on project settings.
The fallback triangle percent sets the percentage of triangles that remain when you're reducing
the source mesh for Nanite.
And then you also have a fallback relative error reduces until the specified error is
reached relative to the mesh size.
So you can actually again adjust these according to what you need.
So we have source import file name.
You'll see that one here.
So this one here is a source mesh used as a higher res LOD type loadout.
So you can actually find that if you need to.
There's a displacement.
What you get displacement options.
Yes, you do.
So you can you can say hey I want this for to be my UV channel for this displacement.
And then also a new feature where we have a displacement map.
So notice we are adding little bits here and there.
But just keep your eyes on that as it evolves.
But this is where it stands at this time.
You may not need any of these.
I haven't really found the need working in ICB effects and virtual production as well
as Final Pixel and games working with game clients.
This isn't always necessarily needed.
But you never know when somebody comes up with a new game idea that may break the bank.
So just keep those things in mind.
Again these are all within the slides for you to take a look at broken down.
So you can actually see each one of these and what they do so you can just keep them
in your memory.
So let's actually talk about a little bit about efficiency.
Now this has changed between 5.0.
I think this went away in 5.1 maybe 5.2.
So we used to have a Nanite debugger.
We don't have that anymore.
We have a thing called a Nanite Enable False.
This basically works just like the debugger.
It's basically just punching this into your search and you can instantly find out what
is Nanite and what is it.
Let me demonstrate.
So in Unreal with my content drawer open here, I can go in here and type in, I'm just going
to cheat and put paste.
Type in Nanite Enable 2 equal signs and false and it will show me everything that is not
necessarily Nanite.
You can see it's showing me all the things that I have not converted to a Nanite object.
We're missing some of the cliffs, actually most of the cliffs, and some of the other
pieces are missing such as simple pieces of geometry and shows everything within my project
that doesn't have it.
So if I convert just one thing, it will now disappear off the list.
So some of the updates, if you are in older versions of Unreal, not aware, we can actually
turn our terrain now into a Nanite object as well as we can do also with the trees and
your foliage, which is super helpful.
You simply can find that foliage where it lives and then now you have the option to
convert it to a Nanite object, which is actually pretty great.
In the terrain itself, I can click on the terrain and simply type in Nanite and you'll
see that we can enable Nanite in here and you'll see that there is a bit of micromanaging
in here such as Nanite LED index, Nanite skirt enabled as well as Nanite skirt depth.
So it's basically allowing you to control the draw method and you'll see here it says
LED level of the landscape when generating the Nanite mesh mostly there for debug reasons.
So most of these are mainly just to be able to check things out if you run into some performance
hits.
Now let's talk a little bit about virtual shadow maps.
We do get into them pretty deep in the other classes here.
So we're going to talk a bit about how they work overall and then how you can actually
maybe edit things a bit here.
So it significantly increases shadow resolution to match highly detailed Nanite geometry,
unlike shadow maps which are like a texture projection.
So we're not doing that in this particular case and you can see why they are the three
musketeers Nanite virtual shadow maps and Lumen they all work together.
Now what what what strength it brings to the table is a plausible soft shadows.
It gives you with reasonable controllable performance costs.
It provides a simple solution that works by default with limited amounts of adjustment
needed and replace the many stationary lights that we normally have in a regular baking
scenario techniques with a single unified path.
So anytime you're actually building your lights and a couple things I want to point
out when now we do get into light optimization here.
So I don't want to dive too deep into this but I do want to point out a few things.
You do want to make sure all your static lighting is off in your project settings.
And again you do want to use a virtual shadow maps but you got to remember I keep saying
this but it's made for Lumen not intended for unreal standard baking.
Unreal will let you know too if you have some things off that on that don't need to be.
If you want to switch to baking you must change your shadow settings in the project settings
and make sure that Lumen is completely off everywhere but you also need to make sure
your lights are no longer movable and the fact that if you want to be able to get your
light to be able to generate some GI with that baking type of method.
Now in our intro to lighting classes and other classes we talk about how you can use some
CVARS to adjust your shadows but you also can do so in the soft source options in some
of your lights.
Now again we get into that a bit more in our other classes for lighting so keep those things
in mind and you'll see here a soft angle source angle I should say I said soft source angle
but it's mainly this guy.
So this source angle allows us to go in here and soften that shadow and again we get into
this and our hardening.
We get into this a bit more in our optimizing for lighting class which is our next class
but I just wanted to point out how realistic and how nice these come out.
It's really great to get this on the fly and again all your lights need to be set movable
with that.
Here's your few links with some more resources talking about these particular topics.
That's it with this one and in the next video we're going to take a look at understanding
LODs.